the san francisco 49ers just a couple
hours down the road for me at the
greenbriar in white sulphur springs west
virginia getting ready for their return
to metlife stadium
will jimmy garoppolo be playing
quarterback for the 49ers on sunday
here's chris's guy kyle shanahan
addressing that
reality on wednesday
uh yeah i'll be surprised if jimmy gets
back later in the week i know he's still
pulling to do it um but uh yeah nick's
ready to go and um if something happens
nick cj will be ready to go nick's got a
lot of playing time with us in 2018
prepared him for moments like this he
always does a good job in practice and
excited to see him get his opportunity
yeah nick mullins started eight games
back in 2018 when jimmy garoppolo had
the torn acl remember he suffered that
week three two years ago in kansas city
mullins played well
uh and and it's it's the system i don't
want to take anything away from jimmy
garoppolo yeah but it's the system and
mullins knows the system it's timing
it's precision it's doing your reads
properly it's not decision making from
the standpoint of you go out there and
you decide what's best it's making the
right decisions within the confines of
the decisions that have already been
made for you exactly by kyle shanahan in
that offense right so i i don't know
that the offense is going to have a
major drop-off
from
jimmy garoppolo who's been so so
let's let's let's be yeah objective
about it it's been so so so far this
season and you go to a guy that knows
the offense even better now than he did
when he was thrust into service two
years ago chris no i mean i think you
you you make all the the right points
you do you know jimmy garoppolo i will
say this he played really well on a
banged up leg last week i mean he did a
great job of kind of sucking it up and
made a lot of big time throws uh to give
them the lead going into the halftime so
that's that stinks because it looked
like it was gonna be one of those games
where they he could build on something
right where you went okay yeah i know
it's the jets but man he made a lot of
good throws and plays on third down and
there was a lot of pauses to build on so
that that does hurt but nonetheless
you're right and nick mullins i just
know from talking to kyle over the years
about the player and everything like
that i mean he he feels about nick
mullins like he's part of the coaching
staff almost that he's he's that kind of
you know backup quarterback he knows
every little nuance of what everybody's
supposed to do you know sometimes as a
quarterback you might not know what the
right tackle is supposed to do with some
run play exactly or what the call is
you know he's all over those things and
you're right with shanahan and with all
the great
coordinators we see in football it's
about executing the system they're not
reinventing the wheel you're literally
just doing what the coach told you to do
all week and i think that's where yes
they're not going to fall off they'll
still be able to implement all the same
offense to what you're saying he knows
the offense probably better than jimmy
garoppolo to your point and so all the
plays that shanahan has at the line of
scrimmage hey if the defense plays this
we'll run this play if they run this
defense let's check it to the other play
and he'll be all over those type of
things and then as we've seen before too
kyle makes the pass game very easy for
the quarterbacks especially with the
play-action pass game and a lot of times
because he's such an attacker of schemes
he gets a defense in a in a formation he
knows they're going to get in and then
he hey we're going to run this
play-action pass and all i want you to
do is read this one guy if he goes this
way throw to that guy if he goes that
way throw to this guy and uh i think
nick mullins will certainly be able to
orchestrate that offense just as long as
he doesn't make those you like hey i
haven't played in a while type mistakes
right that's the only thing you worry
about and that's what we saw a little
last week in the jets game i hope he got
that out of his system
well he gets a chance to actually
prepare and be ready to go instead of
being thrust into the game and the
reality is this the guy's got some
talent he broke all of brett favre's
records at southern miss back in
2013 through 2016 undrafted in 2017 and
now in his fourth nfl season and getting
another opportunity most likely to show
what he can do which uh you know i i
don't know that it complicates decisions
for the 49ers after the season but
depending upon how healthy garoppolo is
and how well the team does and how well
he plays there may be a decision to make
about who the quarterback is for 2021
and beyond other injuries for the 49ers
tevin coleman is likely out for a month
with a knee injury where he mostered has
the knee injury it's time to activate
jarrod mckinnon on your fantasy rosters
folks i got him not that anyone cares
about my team you care about your own
team so for your own team you may want
to go get jared mckinnon he may be this
week's jordan reed well you're right he
could be i mean he showed glimpses of it
last week he did i think that's the
exciting thing for the 49ers is this
jared mckinnon this guy that was signed
two years ago we gave him some money up
front we're so excited about we've seen
nothing from him and it's been
unfortunate not some money yeah i think
him some money what was it all the money
where do they give over 10 guaranteed
right or 10 something like right
as the running back market goes it was
stunning yes the contract they gave him
was stunning and tears in acl right
before the start of his first season
with the team then has you know it
sometimes we always assume that the acl
surgery was a success and rehab's had a
schedule and everything's fine until it
isn't and he missed all of 2019 as well
and yeah he got a huge contract from the
49ers and there was a real question
where they're gonna even bring him back
this year and maybe it's good that they
kept him around on a four-year 30
million dollar contract yeah no you're
right it is it's just for this moment
right here you know the the injury bug
is going rampant through the 49ers
football team and man no mozer no tevin
coleman you're down to two running backs
on your roster and you're sitting there
going well we have a plethora of running
backs we'll be good no issues here man
two go down first two weeks and here you
are down to two i mean you you get one
injury this weekend you're you're you're
worried about
the rest of the game and what you're
gonna do you might get scared to run the
football i mean really so it's a great
opportunity for jarrett mckinnon who
last week had a third in 31 where he
picked it up and ran it had a big like
50 yard run down the left sideline that
was great looked good in the pass game
which is what he was really brought
there to do and that's where i just
wonder if that's what happens this week
with mckinnon in the game do we see more
of a
pass to the running back type offense
out of shanahan and nick mullins who's
like you said a good decision maker he's
got a good quick release and pretty
accurate and how he gets the ball out it
could fit i'll be interested to see
where kyle goes with this
there's no
jerick mckinnon equivalent on the pass
rush and nick bosa out for the year with
the tourney cl solomon thomas out for
the year with the torn acl and d ford
out of practice on wednesday back
problem they signed ziggy ansa but i
don't think that's going to be nearly
enough to give them what they need it's
unbelievable they still should be able
to handle the giants because
it's the giants yeah but this doesn't
bode well for you know the tougher
portion of the schedule which is coming
this early soft spot has worked out well
for the 49ers to have that injury
disaster happened against the woeful and
hapless jets when it was 31-13 still the
final score even with all the injuries
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports